right now we want to introduce you to
Gerald Posner and he is the author of
several books his most recent is this
one God's bankers a history of money and
power at the Vatican it's published by
Simon & Schuster mr. Posner who is God's
bankers it happens to be you are guys
who are God's bankers they change you
know every twenty years or so but for
the most part they are in fact the
bishops and Cardinals of the Catholic
Church and the one person who runs the
Vatican Bank is the Pope he's the only
shareholder of the Vatican Bank
now they hire laymen to run the details
of the in and outs of money but the
persons the people responsible for the
finances of the Vatican are in fact the
same people run the religion how big is
the Vatican Bank how much money does it
hold who has access to it yeah you know
it's sort of a reverse order who has
access to it is a very small group of
people by its charter was created in the
middle of World War two has only been
around for seven years in a two thousand
year old institution the only people
that are supposed to have access to it
our citizens of Vatican City religious
orders and Catholic Charities in
practice it's been manhandled and
misused for years by everyone from
wealthy Italians to people wanted to
launder money through it but that aside
who has control over it not only the
Pope who's the only shareholder of the
Vatican Bank but in addition it's about
the size of let's say a small community
bank in the u.s. seven to ten billion
dollars a year not an enormous that book
goldman sachs makes them pale and any
significance but enough money Peter when
it's running the dark without any
oversight or any transparency to cause
plenty of problems over the decades and
that's what it's done mr. Posner why was
it formed during World War two
oh that's the u.s. to me the key
question in a 700 page book why was the
Vatican Bank formed will tell you a lot
about the problems that has gotten into
it was formed in the middle of World War
two in order to avoid the British and
Americans who are having a blacklist to
stop neutral countries from working with
the enemy so we were looking to stop all
of these neutral countries in Europe and
we put on we mean the United States and
Britain put on the blacklist in 1940 and
41 Liechtenstein and Luxembourg and San
Marino and Monaco
we put on Switzerland we put on every
neutral country in Europe except for one
the Vatican the Vatican developed its
own Bank it went dark and continued to
do business with the Germans and the
Italian fascists through the war they
played both sides they didn't know who
was going to win
so they invested in both what's the
purpose of the bank why do they need a
bank what's the purpose of it there is
no purpose to it that couldn't be served
if they dissolved it the they didn't
have a bank for the first nineteen
hundred and thirty years of their
existence the only reason they formed
one was to sort of circumvent the rules
in World War two but now it's a matter
of national pride
so when Pope Francis came into power in
2013 he said I'm going to reform it but
I may also abolish it he could do it
with a simple decree but the
traditionalist in the church who liked
the fact that they have a permanent
observer status at the UN that they are
a sovereign entity as well as a
religious entity they like the bank
because to them is the equivalent of a
central bank they want to keep it if
nothing else because they think that
it's burnish is their reputation a bit
it does but it's also caused a lot of
headaches for them over time is there
evidence of misuse of the bank it's hard
to catalogue I think one of the reasons
the book is so thick is that the the
evidence of the chronicle sort of a bad
use of the bank is continues decade
after decade with each successive Pope
coming in saying I'm going to cleaned up
so that you have for instance in World
War two they turn out to be doing
business with the Germans and then in
the 1960s it's misused by a group of
Italian bankers one of whom ends up dead
under London Bridge he opens the book
another one who's a major businessman
who ends up dead and cyanide in a jail
and after that 70s and 80s the Vatican
paid a quarter billion dollars to banks
for restitution the Italian prosecutors
had indicted the bishop who ran the bank
and they said we've cleaned it up we now
know in the 90s in the early 2000s the
Italian politicians like the Prime
Minister Giulio Andreotti were running
slush funds to the Vatican Bank titled
under religious orders running tens of
millions of dollars to pay everything
from their wife's jeweller to slush
funds for politicians
so it's until the last few years has
been a source of consolation scandal for
the church where does the money for the
bank mr. Posner come from it comes from
cash that is given by religious orders
much of the money is raised by religious
orders comes in cash and then it's
deposited into the bank who pays an
interest rate back to those religious
orders for the deposits take the
deposits and they use it for very safe
investments they don't one thing I must
say for the Vatican Bank it's one of the
safest investors around they own prime
real estate in the heart of London they
bought in World War two
they bought major shares of American top
100 companies in the 1940s and they've
held them for years they don't loan
money so they had none of the crazy
loans at American and European banks had
that almost took them under so they're
very safe on their investments some of
the money also comes from sources it
shouldn't have an account like the money
launderers or like the the 1% of
Italians evading taxes in the last three
years to Pope Francis as credit they
have closed about 3,500 of those
accounts that should not exist I think
the bank basically is down to the core
accounts it's supposed to have for
religious orders now what did the how
does the Catholic Church otherwise bank
if if not through this back through
correspondent banks so one of the things
that before the Vatican Bank existed
they didn't need any Vatican Bank
because they did all of their work
through the Bank of Italy in the Bank of
Rome and the Bank of England and Chase
Manhattan they used all the
international banks as they normally
would the problem with those banks and
doing that as a country is that the
international banking investigators in
the countries in which you're using the
bank whether it's Chase Manhattan - the
Bank of England they can follow your
money so when you're transferring five
million dollars through Chase Manhattan
American investigators from the Treasury
Department can see where that's going
that's what the Vatican wanted to stop
they wanted their own sort of secrecy in
terms of a National Bank and they got it
but it's created problems for them what
kind of problems the problems that you
would expect when you're dealing with
billions of dollars no transparency and
a lack of oversight this is I think the
real core issue in in the book 80% of
the clerics who are involved in running
the Vatican Bank over the years are
well-intentioned and really wanted to do
the right thing as they saw it for the
Catholic Church 10 to 20 percent didn't
want to do the right thing and what I
mean by that is they weren't always
personally taking money and building up
a personal fortune it's not as though
any of the bishops involved in the
scandals in the 1970s or 80s ended up
with a grand house on Lake Jean
and fleet of Rolls Royces and Ferraris
what they did in fact is they made money
from illegal operations that they then
stashed into what I call their own
account in case they could use it to
gain power in the Vatican and the
perfect example that Bishop Paul March
Incas who was an from Cicero Illinois as
Chicago American Archbishop who came to
run the Vatican Bank he knew nothing
about finances by the way he read six
books about finances but he was loyal to
the Pope Pope Paul the sixth appointed
him to run the bank 1970 ran it for 18
years he amassed about a four to six
million dollar slush fund from all these
deals with questionable characters and
he used it when the Polish Pope came in
when john paul ii became pope he used it
to help that pope destroy communism in
his native Poland and bring down
solidarity it endeared march incas and
the Vatican Bank to the new pope it
built up power for the Vatican Bank and
for March Incas so the money that was
gotten from ill-gotten gains wasn't news
necessarily for our own personal
purposes but what I call the internecine
power struggles within the Vatican for
power and and closeness to the Pope
what's the catholic church's history
with money with money with MAO
the reason Peter that this turns out to
be thank goodness I had a publisher they
was willing to allow me to expand this
book because I pitched to them an idea
in 2005 that said this book is about
world war two in the Vatican then you
end up with a 200 year history they let
me do that because I kept finding that
every time I thought I had the story I
had to bring it back a little bit
earlier and the key part of that was you
just asked what's the Vatican's
relationship to money you find out when
you go back just 150 years ago they did
not like the idea of capitalism they
disdained that the Bible said no lending
at interest it was used for you couldn't
do it and capitalism was an idear mixed
in with modernism free thinking it was
very dangerous to the idea of an
autocratic role so not only did they
have disdain for capitalism but they
viewed it really as the province of
heretical Protestants and Jews they had
a twice borrow money from the
Rothschilds I talk about this much to
the disdain of the traditionalists but
once they lost their empire you have to
remember the Pope's were not just heads
of the Roman Catholic Church they were
King
they ran a 15,000 square mile empire
called the papal States anybody who's
seen The Borgias on SH Oh knows it all
too well they didn't look like Jeremy
Irons but they nevertheless wore Pope
kings they levy taxes and collected fees
that paid the bills
when they lost the empire in 1870 they
had a scramble to figure out how to
bring in money selling indulgences chits
of paper to forgive sins didn't pay all
the bills asking the faithful to send in
the contributions to the Pope didn't pay
all the bills so they slowly and
grudgingly embraced the concepts of
capitalism and in 1942 in the middle of
the war when they formed the Vatican
Bank it's as though they go from an
institution that really is looking at
capitalism with a bit of disdain to
embracing capitalism and putting it on
steroids for the next 70 years they are
engaged in some of what Pope Francis
would call savage capitalism so the
change in the church's view toward money
is as dramatic in the last 70 years as
anything in his 2,000 year history at
what point during it first of all
where'd you get on to the story why
actually from my first book back in 1986
I put out a biography of Joseph Mengele
the Nazi doctor and in doing the
research for that in 1984 I was down in
Buenos Aires and got access to the
federal police files on Mengele through
persistence and a bit of luck in those
files I found documents about German war
criminals arriving in Argentina with the
help of a priest in Rome Father Weber
Anton Weber and a bishop alles Udo and I
thought to myself that's that's
interesting a priest and a bishop and
Nazi war criminals I put that in the
back of my mind and said one day I'm
gonna find a publisher who's going to
allow me to go off and do that subject
and it took me until 2005 and ten books
later to find a publisher in Simon &
Schuster that said alright we're willing
to let you go the story turned out to be
very different than I expected because
not getting into it until I started the
book it turned out to be about money not
necessarily world war two World War 2
was also about money so if you had said
to me what do you think the story's
about I would have thought it was about
ideology possibly Nazi sympathizing
whether the church was too afraid of
Bolshevism and the and Stalin and the
Communists that they sidled up to the
Nazis but it turned out to be the hard
dollars and cents in the end that was
the tale
Gerald Posner how many books have you
written 12 books now although if I write
them as slowly as this won't have many
more they the good news about as you
well know as authors I think David
Jurgen years ago on the prize his book
about oil was several years late in
publishing it and he published it during
the first Gulf War so there was
tremendous interest in it I was supposed
to have this done and published in 2011
or 2012 at the latest but I was running
slow with my wife Trish who works with
me
we would have published under the
pontificate of Benedict and I think the
reaction to the book would have not been
as interesting Francis has energized the
church the idea that Francis is a
reforming Pope the idea that he says
things different than his predecessors
he's brought attention to the Catholic
Church not just for Catholics but for
non Catholics as well so the risks and
the book ends on a note of optimism
although it's a very hard history it
ends on a note of optimism because I do
think Francis is trying to reform it so
this remains a history and is not the
bank going forward so it's a very
different book publishing under
Francis's papacy and that's just the
luck of when you publish in this case
being slow helped what has Francis said
publicly about the Vatican Bank anything
publicly he said all the right things
but that didn't necessarily convince me
he was going to be the real deal when it
came to the Vatican Bank because every
other Pope has said the right things
when they became Pope about reforming
the bank and they failed to do so so
when he became Pope Peter in 2013 and he
said I'm going to reform the bank I'm
more or less said to Tricia oh sure I've
heard that before but but he changed my
mind in the following way
first of all whoever is Pope today they
would have to be reforming the bank and
the reason for that is it's a quirk of
finances but in 99 Italy decided to go
with the euro when it did that meant the
Vatican was in a quandary because they
used the Italian lira for their own
currency so they had to decide whether
they wanted to print their own currency
or go with the euro so they decided to
go with the euro they didn't know when
they went with the euro that meant that
Brussels wanted some oversight on their
central reserved their Vatican Bank so
as a result of Brussels coming in they
the Vatican have had to pass their
first-ever law against the financing of
terrorism in 2011 their first-ever law
against money laundering in 2011 they
never had a law against money laundering
there
first ever law against how much money
you could bring in undisclosed into the
Vatican so they had to come somewhat
compliant by the European standards but
Francis has done it with enthusiasm and
vigor what I mean by that is he's
brought in independent outsiders layman
who are in fact really trying to change
the culture of no transparency and make
it a compliant bank moving forward in
the 21st century he may succeed he needs
to be Pope for another three to five
years to have the it take effect all the
way down the bureaucracy what is the
official name of this bank the the
Institute for the works of religion
Institute opera opera religion and then
I always love that that the Institute
for the works of religion is the Vatican
Bank so sometimes the don't go always by
the name of the institution look behind
the curtain to see what it's really
doing is there a physical location there
is engage that affect the physical
location I'm glad you asked me that is
the medieval tower inside a Vatican City
a sixth is the six it's and in this
tower is where the bank is located it
has no other branch anywhere in the
world it only ATMs for the branch are
inside about a considerin it's the only
bank in the world that has Latin as one
of the languages on the ATMs one of the
small footnotes to the story the Vatican
Bank could you or I open an account
there in the bad old days we might have
been able to open an account there if we
knew a cardinal who was a friend of ours
but today we would have a great deal of
difficulty doing it you're only supposed
to open it if you're a religious order
or a charity however the way around it
was the following Giulio Andreotti who
was seven-time prime minister post-war
prime minister in Italy died a year and
a half ago that may be the most
prominent post-war politician he knew a
Monsignor who opened up an account the
two of them are on the account it was
called the Cardinal Spellman foundation
there was no such institutional
organization anywhere in the world
except in the Vatican Bank and through
it we now have the records that he
Andreotti ran about 60 million in cash
over the years
for everything from paying for his
wife's jeweler to slush funds for other
politicians so if you had the right
connections you could get a deal
Valentino the fashion designer ends up
having his main showroom his retail
showroom on a street in Rome that's like
Madison Avenue or Fifth Avenue it
recently became known that he was paying
a hundred dollars a year for rent when
everybody around here was paying about
six hundred thousand euros for rent he
knew a Cardinal who was a friend who cut
him a deal so that's the way the Vatican
in Italy is operated for years this
incestuous relationship and that's
unfortunately the answer to your
question is could we have open up an
account no unless we had the right
connections Gerald Posner how
cooperative if at all was the Vatican in
your research oh I'd like to be able to
say that they were cooperative but they
weren't you know I asked for access to
the so-called secret archives they're
called that they're actually the private
archives of the Pope that's where the
World War two business documents are
about the Vatican Bank and the Bishop of
Miami Bishop when ski here lobbied on my
behalf for access and the bishop in in
Washington who's the nun seal to
Washington lobbied on my behalf but the
bishop who runs the Vatican archives
said no that forced me Peter to do it
the old-fashioned way I had to go out to
the institution's I knew had done
business with the Vatican Bank the banks
the insurance companies like Generali
Allianz Munich Rey go into their files
and their private archives and pull up
the transactions that had been done with
Rome 50 60 and 70 years ago it was a
slower way of doing it I've also called
on the Pope since the publication of
this book in a Los Angeles Times op-ed
in March I asked for the Pope to release
the bank's World War 2 files and the
files of the wartime Pope there was no
response I asked in when he came to
America and a Washington Post editorial
with the same thing and there's been no
response I am hopeful that Francis will
prove to be not just a reformer going
back in the Vatican banks history but
also going forward he can do that by
releasing the bank's World War 2 files
so we know exactly what they did with
the Germans mr. Posner what are your
former book secrets of the kingdom the
inside story of the Saudi US connection
how do you get the information or why do
you go looking for these stories but you
know that's why I always say that when
you sign the book with a publisher you
never know what the story is if you know
what the story is but I'm doing a book
on the Battle of the Bulge I'm doing a
book on a slice of history I'm doing
Lincoln's assassination I pretty much
know what the stories and the question
is how can I flush out and tell a
different narrative than many other fine
writers are told over time when I'm
doing something that's a living subject
like the Saudi royal family or the
Vatican Bank I throw out the gauntlet it
to everybody I mean I read everything
that's available on the subject I marked
down names initially not knowing whether
they're alive or dead still for an
interview and an arrow down to the the
my wish list of people that I'd like to
interview and a lot of people say no a
lot of people give what I call on the
record stiff formal interviews and
occasionally what happens in my
profession is you meet somebody who's
after a couple of meetings says to you
know they take a liking to you they say
maybe we should have a beer one night
and we can talk
that's opens the door and eventually
they'll say I know somebody you should
talk to over here who worked for as a
former auditor I know somebody over here
and you never know where that path is so
for instance in this book I'm able to
show for the first time on the record
that the Vatican did business with
insurance companies they were German
there might be somebody else who could
say they did business with with arms
manufacturers or pharmaceutical
companies I didn't have that door open
to me so you end up pursuing the
information that you have is this the
absolute final word on the finances of
the Vatican no but it's certainly a
thorough word on what I was able to find
out here's the book Gerald Posner is the
author God's bankers a history of money
and power in the Vatican and we're
watching you're watching I should say
the Miami Book Fair here on book TV on
c-span 2 our live coverage continues and
in just a moment you're going to hear
from a couple of authors who also happen
to be the former and the current US poet
laureate and this panel will be
beginning in just a minute Juan Felipe
is the current